In this video we're
going to talk a
little bit about amines.
And these are just organic
compounds where you have a
nitrogen bonded to groups
that contain carbon.
So if I were to just draw some
amines right here, you could
have something like this where
you have a nitrogen bonded to
two hydrogens and then maybe
some type of carbon chain.
Maybe it's just one
carbon right here.
So maybe you have a carbon,
which is also bonded to three
hydrogens like this.
In this case you would
have a primary amine.
If you have the nitrogen
bonded to two carbons.
So if you have something
like this, a nitrogen
bonded to two carbons.
So it has one carbon
chain right there.
And I'm just drawing
methyl groups here.
The chain could keep on going.
Maybe you have two like that.
And then you have a hydrogen
right there.
This would be a secondary
amine.
And then finally you could
imagine, if you had it bonded
to three, it would be
a tertiary amine.
And this is just to get you
introduced to the terminology.
CH3, just like that.
Now like all of the other new
groups or new types of
compounds that we've explored,
what I want to do is just
introduce you to the
naming of it.
Because one, that lets you
recognize them when you hear
their names.
But it also, I think on some
level, familiarizes you with
their structure.
So let's do a couple
of naming examples.
I drew these ahead of time.
And in general, just to
remember, amines are a pretty
high-priority group.
Out of all the things that we've
learned so far, the only
thing that is a higher
priority is
actually the alcohols.
Or actually the thiols, which I
don't even remember if I did
a video on it.
But thiols are just like
alcohols, but instead of an
oxygen you have a sulfur.
So this comes right
after those.
So let's think about this
one right here.
So we always want to look for
our longest carbon chain.
And our longest carbon
chain is right here.
One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven carbons.
You want to start numbering
it closer to
the functional group.
One, two, three, four,
five, six, and seven.
And then the functional
group is on the two
carbon right there.
So first of all,
seven carbons.
We would use the prefix hept.
So it would be heptan.
Let me write that down.
So it'd be heptan.
And since our functional group
is an amine in this situation,
it has a higher priority than
the fact this is an alkane.
So this will actually
define the suffix.
So we would then say well then
on the two carbon-- let me do
this in new color-- on the two
carbon right over here we have
the amine group.
So it's heptan-2-amine.
And we're done.
We know that we have an amine
group on the two carbon.
Now let's do this one.
This one's a little
bit more hairy.
So first of all, we always want
to figure out the longest
carbon chain.
And it looks like the ring
is going to be the
longest carbon chain.
We have one, two, three, four,
five, six carbons.
So this thing right here
is the longest chain.
We only have one, two
carbons right there.
One carbon and one carbon,
right over there.
So our root is going
to be cyclohexane.
I want to make sure I
have enough space.
Cyclohexane.
And then once again it's an
amine, so this is going to
take higher priority.
So we're not just going to put
an e at the end and call this
cyclohexane.
This takes higher priority.
So it will actually
define the suffix.
And another thing to think about
is you could say, OK
this is going to be the
one, this is going
to be the one carbon.
And so you could call this
cyclohexan-1-amine.
But in general, if this is
defining it, you always assume
that you're going to start
numbering right there at
number one.
So you could just call
this cyclohexanamine.
If it's written like this you
assume that the one carbon is
where the amine group
is attached.
Now what else do we have
on this thing?
We took care of the amine.
We took care of the cyclo.
Well we have this ether
right here.
And this ether has
one, two carbons.
If it was just a two carbon
chain, it would be ethane.
But since we have it's an ether,
it's bonded to this
oxygen, we call this ethoxy.
So that right there is ethoxy.
And we're going to have to think
about how we're going to
number this.
So I'll leave that alone.
And what are these over here?
Well this is a methyl group.
That's a CH3 implicitly.
You don't see it drawn.
There's a carbon there.
And if carbon is neutral, it
has to have four bonds.
And if you only draw one of
them, the other three are
assumed to be the hydrogen.
So this is a methyl group.
And then this is also
a methyl group.
So we have dimethyl.
So this is also a methyl
group right over there.
And when we think about
numbering, we could number
from one, two three.
Or we could start numbering
one, two, three.
And in general, you want to go
numbering in the direction
where you hit the functional
group first. So we want to go
one, two, three,
four, and five.
So this right here
is 5-ethoxy.
And this is one, two dimethyl.
These two combined, you
would call this
one comma two dimethyl.
And then when you want to list
them in order, the ethoxy
would take precedence in
alphabetical because the di
you shouldn't count in the
alphabetical order.
This is just saying
two methyls.
So you really just want to look
at the two of whatever
you're talking about.
M comes after e in alphabetical
order.
So this is going
to be 5-ethoxy.
Actually let me just rewrite
the whole thing.
So this is going
to be 5-ethoxy
1,2-dimethylcyclohexanamine.
And we're done.
This was probably one
of the longest words
we've used in naming.
But hopefully you see when you
break down the different
pieces, it actually makes
sense that it
represents this molecule.